which rumors in the 1920s what handles
back in the news baby teapot dome
scandal just gonna have a little drink
of apple juice if coolidge wants to be
remotely popular end prohibition dude at
least harding had some drip i mean look
at coolidge
what is that dude it's no [ __ ] secret
i bought a house it was eight thousand
dollars yeah wait this person is making
fun of me
oh my god
it's a lot of money socialism went no
house that's good dude shut up hold on
stock market crashed
you know what this means right
no more chicken tendies
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] everything is this dude
the great depression was not poggers
[Laughter]
this is so stupid
what the [ __ ]
which streamers
today we're watching uh
president kennedy's gotta does this guy
think that like i'm the only twitch
streamer what's going on i feel like
he's exclusively just making fun of me
speech f's in the chat for nixon dude
there's no way nixon was going to win
that race president kennedy not my
president all right let's watch someone
in chat just said that kennedy has an
ugly mug no you are blocked dude guys
i'm not saying kennedy isn't a lib but
saying he's ugly that's i mean honestly
who wouldn't tap that don't be an idiot
dude don't make me do emotes only guys
can i get some chicken wings i'm
starving in here chat now the the cuban
missile crisis was not poggers
what the [ __ ]
oh what the [ __ ] this is insane
yeah i know it's my chat
no this person is making fun of me okay
i i know it's literally you guys in the
background there is no like saying it's
literally this is my chat
it's my [ __ ] sub uh this is yeah he's
[ __ ] in here right now show yourself
[ __ ]
this is hilarious this is pretty funny
this is really good chat the cupid
missile crisis was not poggers oh that's
hilarious dude yeah ria gonorrhea expert
memer gets a [ __ ] shout out in here i
don't know if they're in here right now
but i'm baffled by how accurate this is
i heard this hoover dude's pretty cool
hopefully it doesn't do something
horrible sasha react to this you get a
bunch of people visiting your channel
and they will be very confused by almost
all your videos and probably call you a
nerd and then leave again anyway all
right we're done uh with this part of
the broadcast